people who live in an apartment complex
in downtown las vegas
are wondering when these stairs are
going to be replaced this all happened
last month we've been covering it since
the beginning over at washington and
bruce
a car hit the stairs tenants had to move
out but they reached out to 8 news now
for help they need those stairs to get
into the apartment
joe moeller's been working to get some
answers for them he joins us live with
what he's learned still no stairs joe
well that's right those tenants who live
upstairs are still elsewhere now while
the city did come by and they inspected
the building and they say it is secure
so that nobody can get upstairs where it
is unsafe i'll give you a live look this
evening
at what it looks like you can see the
caution status tape is still upstairs
and there are no stairs
the owner says they were hoping to get
permits today now this all started back
on february 14th
tenants say it took several days for
them to get any direction on
what was happening with the stairs as
they used a ladder and a chain to get to
their units
both upstairs tenants moved out one
family was put in a hotel thanks to an
eight news now
viewer the owners do not have a legal
obligation to pay for another place
the city told me today there is no
timeline on when this has to be fixed
sunday green with anderson steel and
fabrication saw our story and
wants to help get these stairs fixed
well we really want to get in touch with
them to try to fix it you know get it
done you know like we've
rolled around there's standard stairways
stairways and stuff so
it's not hard to fix you know so i don't
know what happened and
what's taking them so long but it could
be fixed
green there is waiting to hear back from
the owners i did talk to the downstairs
tenant
who were sir tenants today who were
served an eviction notice saying the
tenant
is suffering permitting or maintaining a
nuisance on or about the property
the tenants say they believe because
they are shedding light on this problem
they are now being evicted now back out
here live those tenants there do plan to
fight the eviction
and now saying they have to move out of
the building for these repairs to happen
as well now the city
uh did say they will be back out here to
monitor the situation at this building
next week reporting live in las vegas
john mullen 8 news now